c'è una storia che va avanti da oltre
duemila anni e la storia di una
contrapposizione tra la città e la
campagna già esopo raccontava una storia
è diventata poi abbastanza famosa di un
topo di campagna e di un topo di città e
il topo digitali diceva ma chi te lo fa
fare e di vivere in un ambiente così
difficoltoso sotto la pioggia poi per
farla breve il topo di campagna va in
città seguendo il consiglio del suo
amico vengono quasi derubati uccisi
insomma e allora ripensa della
tranquillità della campagna e poi il
manzoni con l'addio ai monti e diciamo
il viaggio di renzo verso una milano un
po in subbuglio in quei tempi
fino arrivare a cooper un poeta del 700
che racconta in un famoso motto questa
contrapposizione con un po d'ironia dice
dio ha creato la campagna gli uomini
hanno creato le città rimanendo un po
vago su quale fosse l'ambiente migliore
ma andiamo a
diciamo un momento in cui questo
confronto si è
maturato baudelaire inventò a questo
termine la flanery vuol dire che si
istituzionalizza come positivo l'atto di
passeggiare a scoprire le nostre città
siamo nell'ottocento e cominciano a
fiorire nelle città parigi in quel caso
ma anche londra con benjamin e altri i
ristoranti che conosciamo oggi i primi
centri commerciali in città i negozi
teatri e quindi c'è questa un atto
positivo che baudelaire
stigmatizza di
camminare a scoprire queste meraviglie
d'altro canto
sempre negli stessi anni a metà
ottocento john moore e poi più tardi
geddes in scozia
inventano un altro concetto sempre
recuperando questa storica battaglia per
città e campagna che è quello della wild
ernest insomma inventa per esempio i
palchi nazionali convince un presidente
degli stati uniti ad andare a yosemite e
di fronte a questa bellezza a fronte di
una volontà di costruire lì un'attività
industriale e una diga e decide invece
di creare il primo parco nazionale del
mondo allora
andando avanti
e cercando di care spazio per nuove idee
cerchiamo qui di superare questo
conflitto capire se c'è la possibilità
di trovare un nuovo modo un nuovo patto
tra città e campagna e per fare questo
andiamo su internet nel dizionario
urbano è un sito molto carino che va a
spiegare alcune parole di slang tra cui
una che è quella dell'urbanità che in
italia non è tanto usata però in inglese
si è cosa vuol dire urbanità così
capiamo un po e partiamo da quello che è
la base dell'essere cittadino si dice
una persona felice a 7 44 anni io sono
al limite quindi
che
diciamo in qualche modo ai mezzi per
poter vivere una vita con un punto di
vista ottimista sul futuro e che si
sente differente ancora una volta dalle
persone che vivono alle aree più di
campagna e ancora questo dizionario è
molto precisione indicare sei fattori
peculiari di chi è cittadino nell'anima
il primo che ha poco tempo
lo conoscete tutti questo tema il
secondo che è abbastanza orgoglioso di
essere in una metropoli è abbastanza
curioso aperto al mondo si informa legge
è un po attento anche ai brand re
insomma essere in qualche modo
all'apache e è
assolutamente tollerante c'è una frase
che poi sempre il dizionario urbano
riporta perché queste parole di slang
poi si ritrovano in canzoni o
letterature in questo caso è un famoso
libro è la frase dice mi piace è uno che
ama vivere in città i suoi vestiti sono
sempre nice
diciamo ama circondarsi di gente e
frequentare posti interessanti e poi si
lamenta sempre non avere abbastanza
tempo è un urbanità totale ok da qui
la frase inventata ecco allora poniamo
di superare questa conflitto e
riflettiamo su un elemento delle città
questo e tokyo
vedete l'elemento poi sintetico che fino
ad oggi ha rappresentato le città è la
densità
l'essere diciamo in un ambiente in una
metropoli dove lo spazio è poco dove si
vive compatti dove c'è un intensità di
relazioni uno scontro tra persone
diverse
io la chiamo a volte una sorta di
scatola nera dove interessi contrapposti
magicamente generano benessere
complessivo
ecco allora quello che fino ad oggi si è
pensato ma noi oggi lo vogliamo superare
e che
città volesse dire unione tra quello
spirito urbano che abbiamo definito e
che possiamo poi sintetizzare in una
persona tollerante aperta al mondo
ambiziosa capace di confrontarsi con
l'altro
e l'ambiente urbano quindi la densità la
mancanza di spazi la compattezza i
grattacieli come forma allora quello che
però io vedo è un unico momento nella
storia oggi dove è possibile immaginare
un disaccoppiamento mai accaduto prima
tra lo spirito urbano e la forma urbana
è possibile cioè immaginare in modo un
po provocatorio l'ho chiamata così una
città dei mille minuti chi si occupa di
città sa che va un po di moda
ultimamente dopo le smart city e dopo
altre slogan il tema della città dei 15
minuti
una sorta di paesello
diciamo dove tutto è raggiungibile un
quartiere all'interno di un grande
agglomerato dove alla fine ti trovi e
non ti muovi da
quello spazio di 15 minuti a piedi
perché hai tutte le possibilità di
trovare ecco secondo me invece bisogna
immaginare come unico modo per cogliere
la peculiarità di questo momento storico
grazie a tutta la tecnica che abbiamo e
l'avanzamento umano la possibilità di
immaginare questo disaccoppiamento
smettiamo di pensare che la città sia
solo una questione fisica la città può
finalmente essere anche una questione di
spirito e allora per sintetizzare la in
un tweet la mia idea è che oggi la città
sia ovunque
un cittadino si trovi e che quindi
l'elemento fondamentale non è solo
l'elemento fisico ma è fondamentale
guardare all'elemento di spirito urbano
che prima abbiamo in qualche modo
definito e quindi in qualche modo queste
sono le parole inglesi attuali che
riprendono dopo 150 anni la
contrapposizione tra miur e i palchi
nazionali la wilderness
l'esaltazione della natura e baudelaire
e l'esaltazione della flanery di questa
città vibrante che va conosciuta ecco
oggi questi termini sono i siti quiz chi
durante la pandemia ha lasciato la città
magari ha pensato di venire a jesolo per
esempio o ha pensato di poter fare uno
smile working nomade in qualunque posto
anche il più remoto basta che fosse
collegato a internet basta che fosse
vicino come qui a un aeroporto
basta che avesse delle condizioni per
cui il proprio spirito urbano potesse
esprimersi anche senza una forma urbana
e d'altro canto ci sono i siti de vyver
è una termina abbastanza nuovo che sono
quelli che finita la pandemia
ritorna non invece gita ecco tutto
questo che è la nuova contrapposizione
del topo di campagna del topo di città è
superato e allora per chi fa politica
per chi fa amministrazione per chi si
trova a gestire una città oggi piccolo o
grande che sia il tema
in termini di azioni deve cambiare visto
questo disaccoppiamento mai verificato
tra spirit urbane forma urbana cioè
bisogna passare da quello che è stato
l'atteggiamento
amministrativo politico di punto di
vista sulle città fino ad oggi cioè il
city making faccio la città la città
come forma fisica nei suoi spazi seppure
importanti nei suoi luoghi pubblici e
privati nei suoi edifici nelle sue
infrastrutture
deve essere il focus dell'azione ecco
dal city making occorre passare al far i
cittadini dal fare città a fare i
cittadini dal city making al citizen
making quindi concentrarsi su una serie
di azioni che aiutino le persone che
abita in un certo luogo a essere mediali
trait quindi riprendiamo un po di
termini di prima
curiosi che si informano su fonti
diverse e indipendenti
tolleranti aperti al nuovo capaci di
avere un'ambizione personale ma nello
stesso tempo capaci di accettare il
diverso curiosi verso il mondo allora se
l'attenzione politico amministrativa
fattuale di tutti noi passa in un mondo
diverso dove le città non sono più solo
la loro forma fisica
abbiamo questa inedita occasione di
disaccoppiare la forma urbana dallo
spirito urbano la nostra attenzione deve
passare decisamente dal city making
cities and making e allora per finire
possiamo immaginare in questa città dei
mille minuti che forse oggi in un mondo
che questo è un contatore che a
brevissimo ci porterà oggi a 7 miliardi
di 972 milioni di persone ci porterà a 8
miliardi di persone allora possiamo
immaginare a breve un mondo di 8
miliardi di città dove la dove ognuno di
noi si senta cittadino abbiamo una città
grazie
[Applauso]